au quotidien avec une pastille qu'on a
connu dans la nuit qoussaï oui un gars
une kelly alors avant c'était entre jean
michel et kelly maintenant kelly a
changé de cible c'est à dire regardez
comment ça se fritent tout est entre les
deux entre castaldi et calixa ce fric
tout y salsa se bat ouais
[Musique]
pour le moment nous début d'émission
j'te défonce et je vous ai tous même
défoncé et le crottin jardin elle mesure
12 mètres 50
et tu veux qu'on parle de ce qui se
passe dans tous les futurs ample
toujours là
jamais
c'est fait
et leur fille
cette phase et on perd là bizarrement
wade est en train de masser le cul d'un
mec alors bonne ou autre chose
d'improbable antilles et en string
j'étais vallée du var gard des anciens
ce paribas en fait à tous
ivoire est voilée devant le crif bon
sens inverse ah non c'est gros succès
c'est benjamin bruche et pourquoi il y
aurait tellement triste
parce que pendant ma terre mon événement
dans l'émission
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose pour que vous sachiez ces
coquilles benjamins sont récompensés oui
bassam à karan et kelly dans l'émission
face de même ma femme boit plus
exactement c'est votre femme aurore
merci et chez vous et or qui avaient
ramené clémence émanant avec benjamin
vous aimer d'amour et vous êtes très
drôle tous les ce régal on loge les deux
quand ils sont bons c'est incroyable
frères et soeurs on dirait vraiment que
son grand frère c'est ça c'est d'épouser
mais même dans la vie c'est ça pour de
vrai il est très bons conseils benjamin
c'est un amour du journal turc élite